Thanks again for joining us on learning more about how to create materials in our introductory
course on creating them and using them in Unreal.
We covered different aspects of materials to consider and think about when it comes
to roughness and metallic, grouping those materials and putting them in the appropriate
areas for organization and some of the tools to be able to view things the way that you
would want.
We also talked about looking at animated materials, how to animate them in a scene,
how to get them to look and feel a bit more realistic based on your settings and the inputs
you put in.
And then finally, we looked at creating alpha information or getting alpha information from
our textures and punching them into a material in Unreal to get the believability of cloth
and things with alpha data that we can use and manipulate to the looks that we need.
Thanks again for joining us on this little adventure and learning about Unreal and getting
an introduction to materials.
I'm sure you're going to have a blast and trust me when I say it's pretty addictive.
Thanks again.